while the puck drops on the golden
knights season tomorrow as vegas hosts
the anaheim ducks today the franchise
promoted their best player
to a historic role john treach has the
story john
that's right christian when mark stone
arrived in las vegas all the marquis on
the strip greeted him
in grand fashion he has remained the
headliner as the face of the franchise
and the first captain in vegas golden
knights history
four seasons but one c the golden
knights waited for the right opportunity
and the right man to assume the
leadership
title and role of the franchise they
wanted a great player but more
importantly a rock
solid example and they got stoned the 28
year old is entering his second full
season in vegas and
will be flanked by alternate captains
riley smith and alex betrangelo
stone plays with unbridled enthusiasm
and hustle
and ownership believes the captain's
attitude is contagious
for mark stone with great power comes
great responsibility
and respect special player honestly i
was kind of speechless
um you know for this organization in
three years to
to be where it's at um it's very
humbling for me
um it's a big honor
something that i'm not going to take
lightly and something i'm really excited
to
do to have the opportunity to play for
the stanley cup and
um we're not taking anything for granted
um
we know we have a lot of work to do um
but we're very excited with what we have
what we've become
and now we just want to go out and prove
to everybody and just how good we can be
so get this there are over 600 nhl
players 28
captains and only one wearing the
distinction in vegas and he'll be doing
it for
a while mark stone is under contract
until 2027. christian